most of the questions are fact-based
questions like who did something or when
did something happen and most of the
answers are fairly easy to find so you
know doing as well as a human on that
task is fantastic but it only gets you
part of the way there what happened is
after this was announced that Microsoft
added this great achievement in
machinery and comprehension lots of
customers started coming to Microsoft
saying how can we have that for our
company and this is where we're focused
right now how can we make this
technology work for real problems that
our enterprise customers are bringing in
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
the ability to read and understand
unstructured text and then answer
questions about it is a common skill
among literate humans but for machines
not so much at least not yet and not if
dr. TJ Hazen senior principal research
manager in the engineering and applied
research group at MSR Montreal has to
say he spent much of his career working
on machines speech and language
understanding and particularly of late
machine reading comprehension or MRC on
today's podcast
dr. Hazen talks about why reading
comprehension is so hard for machines
gives us an inside look at the technical
approaches applied researchers and their
engineering colleagues are using to
tackle the problem and shares the story
of how an aha moment with a Rubik's Cube
inspired a career in computer science
and a quest to teach computers to answer
complex text-based questions in the real
world that and much more on this episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
TJ Hazen welcome to the podcast thanks
for having me researchers like to
situate their research and I like to
situate my research or select get you
situated you're a senior principal
research manager in the engineering and
applied research group at Microsoft
Research in Montreal tell us what you do
there what are the big questions you're
asking what are the big problems you're
trying to solve what gets you up in the
morning well I've spent my whole career
working in speech and language
understanding and I think the primary
goal of everything I do is to try to be
able to answer questions so people have
questions and we'd like the computer to
be able to provide answers so that's
sort of the high level goal how do we go
about answering questions now
answers can come from any places right a
lot of the systems that you're probably
aware of like Siri for example or
Cortana or Bing or Google any of them
the answers typically come from
structured places databases that contain
information and for years these models
have been built in a very
domain-specific way if you want to know
the weather somebody built a system to
tell you about the weather right and
somebody else might build the system to
tell you about the age of your favorite
celebrity and somebody else might have
written a system to tell you about the
sports scores and each of them could be
built to handle that very specific case
but that limits the range of questions
you can ask is you have to curate all
this data you have to put it into
structured form and right now what we're
worried about is how can you answer
questions more generally about anything
and the Internet is a wealth of
information
the Internet has got tons and tons of
documents on every topic you know in
addition to the obvious ones like
Wikipedia if you go into any enterprise
to me and you've got manuals about how
their operation works
you've got policy documents you've got
financial reports and it's not typical
that all this information is going to be
curated by somebody it's just sitting
there in text so how can we answer any
question about anything that's sitting
in text we don't have a million or five
million or ten million librarians doing
this
for us but the information is there and
we need a way to get at it is that what
you're working on yes that's exactly
what we're working on I think one of the
difficulties with today's systems is
they seem really smart right sometimes
sometimes they give you fantastically
accurate answers but then you could just
ask a slightly different question and it
can fall on its face that's the real gap
between what the models currently do
which is you know really good pattern
matching some of the time versus
something that can actually understand
what your question is and know when the
answer that it's giving you is correct
let's talk a bit about your group which
out of Montreal is engineering an
applied research and that's an
interesting umbrella at Microsoft
Research you're technically doing
fundamental research but your focus is a
little different from some of your pure
research peers how would you
differentiate what you do from others in
your field well I think there's two
aspects to this the first is that the
lab of Montreal was created as an
offshoot of an acquisition Microsoft
bought Mulumba which was a startup that
was doing really incredible deep
learning research but at the same time
they were a start-up and they needed to
make money so they also had this very
talented engineering team in place to be
able to take the research that they were
doing and deep learning and apply it to
problems where it could go into products
for customers when you think about that
need that they had to actually build
something you could see why they had a
strong engineering team now when I
joined I wasn't with them when they were
a start-up I actually joined them from
Asher where I was working with outside
customers in the azure data science
solution team and I observe lots of
problems that our customers have and
when I saw this new team that we had
acquired and we had turned into a
research lab in Montreal I said I really
want to be involved because they have
exactly the type of technology that can
solve customer problems and they have
this engineering team in place that can
actually deliver on turning something
from a concept into something real
right so I joined and I had this
agreement with my manager that we would
focus on real problems they were now
part of the research environment at
Microsoft but I said that doesn't
restrict us on thinking about blue sky
for our field research we can go and
talk to product teams and say what are
the real problems that are hindering
your products you know what are the
difficulties you have and actually
making something real and we could focus
our research to try to solve those
difficult problems and if we're
successful then we have an immediate
product that could be beneficial well in
any case you're swimming someplace in a
we could do this immediately but you
have permission to take longer or is
there a mandate as you live in this
engineering and applied research group I
think there's a mandate to solve hard
problems I think that's the Mandate of
research if it wasn't a hard problem
than somebody every product would
already have a solution right so we do
want to tackle hard problems but we also
want to tackle real problems that's at
least our focus of our team and there's
plenty of people doing blue sky research
and that's an absolute need as well you
know we can't just be thinking one or
two years ahead research should be also
thinking 5 10 15 years ahead so there's
a whole spectrum so there's a spectrum
but there is a real need I think to fill
that gap between taking an idea that
works well in a lab and turning it into
something that works well in practice
for a real problem and that's the key
and many of the problems that have been
solved by Microsoft have not just been
blue sky ideas but they've come from
this problem space where a real product
says we're struggling with this so it
could be anything it could be like how
does being efficiently rank documents
over billions of documents you don't
just solve that problem by thinking
about it you have to get dirty with the
data you have to understand what the
real issues are so many of these
research problems that we're focusing on
and we're focusing on how do you answer
questions out of documents when the
questions could be arbitrary and on any
topic and you've probably experienced
this if you're going into a search site
for your company that company typically
doesn't have the
of having a big big infrastructure
behind it that's collecting all this
data and doing a sophisticated machine
learning sometimes is really hard to
find an answer to your question and you
know the tricks that people use can be
creative and inventive but often times
trying to figure out what the right
keywords are to get you to an answer is
not the right thing you work closely
with engineers on the path from research
to product so how does your daily
proximity to the people that reify your
ideas as a research or impact the way
you view and do your work as a
researcher well I think when you're
working in this applied research and
engineering space as opposed to a pure
research space it really forces you to
think about the practical implications
of what you're building how easy is it
going to be for somebody else to use
this is it efficient is it gonna run at
scale all of these problems are problems
that engineers care a lot about and
sometimes researchers just say let me
solve the problem first and everything
else is just engineering if you say that
to an engineer they'll be very
frustrated because you don't want to
bring something to an engineer that
works ten times slower then needs to be
used as ten times more memory so when
you're in close proximity and engineers
you're thinking about these problems as
you're developing your methods
interesting because those two things I
mean you could come up with a great idea
that would do it and you pay a
performance penalty in spades right yeah
yeah so sometimes it's necessary
sometimes you don't know how to do it
and you just say let me find a solution
that works and then you spend 10 years
actually trying to figure out how to
make it work in a real product and I'd
rather not spend that time I'd rather
think about you know how can I solve
something and have it be effective as
soon as possible
[Music]
let's talk about human language
technologies they've been referred to by
some of your colleagues as the crown
jewel of AI a speech and language
comprehension is still a really hard
problem
give us a lay of the land both in the
field in general and at Microsoft
Research specifically what's hope in
what's hype and what are the common
misconceptions that run alongside the
remarkable strides you actually are
making I think that word we mentioned
already understand that's really the key
of it or comprehend and is another way
to say it what we've developed doesn't
really understand at least when we're
talking about general purpose AI so the
deep learning mechanisms that people are
working on right now that can learn
really sophisticated things from
examples they do an incredible job of
learning specific tasks but they really
don't understand what they're learning
right so they can discover complex
patterns that can associate things so in
the vision domain you know if you're
trying to identify objects and then you
go in and see what the deep learning
algorithm has learned it might have
learned features that are like you know
if you're trying to identify a dog it
learns features that would say oh this
is part of a leg or this is part of an
ear or this is part of a nose or this is
the tail it doesn't know what these
things are but it knows they all go
together and the combination of them
will make a dog and it doesn't know what
a dog is either but the idea that you
could just feed data in and you give it
some labels and it figures everything
else out about how to associate that
label with that that's really impressive
learning okay but it's not understanding
it's just really sophisticated pattern
matching and the same is true in
language we've gotten to the point where
we can answer general purpose questions
and it can go and find the answer out of
a piece of text and it could do it
really well in some cases and like some
of the examples will give it will give
it who questions and it learns that who
questions should contain proper names or
names of organizations and when
questions should express concepts of
time it doesn't know anything about what
time is but it's figured out the
patterns about how can I relate a
question like when to
an answer that contains time expression
and that's all done automatically
there's no features that somebody sits
down and says oh this is a month and a
month means this and this is a year a
year means this and a month is a part of
a year expert AI systems of the past
would do this they would create ontology
x' and they would describe things about
how things are related to each other and
they would write rules and within
limited domains they would work really
really well if you stayed within a nice
tightly constrained part of that domain
but as soon as you went out and asked
something else it would fall on its face
and so we can't really generalize that
way efficiently if we want computers to
be able to learn arbitrarily we can't
have a human behind the scene creating
an ontology for everything that's the
difference between understanding and
crafting or relationships and
hierarchies versus learning from scratch
we've gotten to the point now where the
algorithms can learn all these
sophisticated things but they really
don't understand the relationships the
way that humans understand it go back to
the sort of lay of the land and how I
sharpened that by saying what's hope and
what's hype could you give us a TBH
answer
well what's hope is that we can actually
find reasonable answers to a extremely
wide range of questions
what's hype is that the computer will
actually understand at some deep and
meaningful level what this answer
actually means I do think that we're
gonna grow our understanding of
algorithms and we're gonna figure out
ways that we can build algorithms I
could learn more about relationships and
learn more about reasoning learn more
about common sense but right now they're
just not at that level of sophistication
yet all right well let's do the podcast
version of your nerd Lunch and Learn
tell us what you're working on in
machine reading comprehension or MRC and
what contributions you're making to the
field right now you know nerd is short
for New England Research & Development
Center I did not which is where I
physically work even though I work
closely and I'm affiliated with the
Montreal lab I work out of the lab in
Cambridge Massachusetts and nerd has a
weekly Lunch and Learn where people
present the
work they're doing or the research that
they're working on and at one of these
luncheon lines I gave this talk on
machine reading comprehension machine
reading comprehension in its simplest
version is being able to take a question
and then being able to find the answer
anywhere in some collection of text as
we've already mentioned it's not really
comprehending at this point it's more
just very sophisticated pattern matching
but it works really well in many
circumstances and even on tasks like the
Stanford question answering data set is
a common competition that people have
competed in question answering by
computer has achieved a human level of
parity on that task okay but that task
itself is somewhat simple because most
of the questions are fact-based
questions like who did something or when
did something happen and most of the
answers are fairly easy to find so you
know doing as well as a human on that
task is fantastic but it only gets you
part of the way there what happened is
after this was announced that Microsoft
added this great achievement in
machinery and comprehension lots of
customers started coming to Microsoft
saying how can we have that for our
company and this is where we're focused
right now like how can we make this
technology work for real problems that
our enterprise customers are bringing in
so we have customers coming in saying I
want to be able to answer any question
in our financial policies or our
auditing guidelines or our operations
manual and people don't ask who or when
questions of their operations manual
they ask questions like how do I do
something or explain some process to me
and those answers are completely
different they tend to be longer and
more complex and you don't always
necessarily find a short simple answer
that's well situated in some context so
our focus at MSR Montrell is to take
this machine reading comprehension
technology and apply it into these new
areas where our customers are really
expressing that there's a need well
let's go a little deeper technically on
what it takes to enable or teach
machines to answer questions and this is
key with limited data that's part of
your equation right right right so when
we go into a new task so if a company
comes to us and says oh here's our
operations manual they often have this
expectation because
we've achieved human parity on some data
set that we can answer any question out
of that manual but when we test the
general-purpose models I've been trained
on these are the tasks on these manuals
they don't generally work well and these
models have been trained on hundreds of
thousands if not millions of examples
depending on what datasets you've been
using and it's not reasonable to ask a
company to collect that level of data in
order to be able to answer questions
about their operations manual but we
need something we need some examples of
what are the types of questions do we
have to understand what types of
questions they asked we need to
understand the vocabulary we'll try to
learn what we can from the manual itself
but without some examples we don't
really understand how to answer
questions in these new demands but what
we've discovered through some of the
techniques that are available transfer
learning is what we refer to as sort of
our model adaptation how do you learn
from data in some new domain and take an
existing model and make it adapt to that
domain we call that transfer learning we
can actually use transfer learning to do
really well in in your domain without
requiring a ton of data so our goal is
to have it be examples like hundreds of
examples not tens of thousands of
examples how's that working now it works
surprisingly well I'm always amazed at
how well these machine learning
algorithms work with all the techniques
that are available now these models are
very complex when we're talking about
our question-answering model it has
hundreds of millions of parameters and
what you're talking about is trying to
adjust a model that is hundreds of
millions of parameters with only
hundreds of examples and through a
variety of different techniques where we
can avoid what we call overfitting we
can allow the generalizations that have
learned from all this other data to stay
in place while still adapting it so it
does well in this specific domain so
yeah I think we're doing quite well
we're still exploring you know what are
the limits and we're still trying to
figure out how to make it work so that
an outside company can easily create the
data set put the data set into a system
push a button the engineering for that
and the researcher that is still ongoing
but I think we're pretty close to being
able to you know provide a solution for
this type of problem all right I'm gonna
push in technically because to me it
seems like that
would be super hard for a machine we
referring to these techniques do we have
to sign an NDA as listeners no no I can
explain stuff that's out yeah domain so
there are two common underlying
technical components that make this work
one is called word embeddings and the
other is called attention word
embeddings are a mechanism where it
learns how to take words or phrases and
express them in what we call vector
space okay so it turns them into a
collection of numbers and it does this
by figuring out what types of words are
similar to each other based on the
context that they appear in and then
placing them together in this vector
space of their near by each other so we
would learn that let's say city names
are all similar because they appear in
similar contexts and so therefore Boston
and New York and Montreal they should
all be close together in this vector
space and blue and red and yellow should
be close together and then advances were
made to figure this out in context so
that was the next step
because some words have multiple
meanings so you know if you have a word
like apples sometimes it refers to a
fruit and it should be near orange and
banana but sometimes it refers to the
company and it should be near Microsoft
in Google so we've developed context
dependent ones so that says based on the
context I'll place this word into this
vector space so it's close to the types
of things that it really represents in
that context that's the first part and
you can learn these word embeddings from
massive amounts of data so we start off
with a model that's learned on far more
data than we actually have
question-and-answer data for the second
part is called attention and that's how
you associate things together and it's
the attention mechanisms that learn
things like a word like who has to
attend to words like person names or
company names and word like when has to
attend to time time and those
associations are learned through this
attention mechanism and again we can
actually learn a lot of associations
between things just from looking at raw
text without actually having it
annotated
once we've learned all that we have a
base and that base tells us a lot about
how language works and then we just have
to have it focus on the task ok so
depending on the task we might have a
small amount of data and we feed in
examples in that small amount but it
takes advantage of all the stuff that
it's learned about language from all
these you know rich data that's out
there on the web and so that's how it
can learn these associations even if you
don't give it examples in your domain
but it's learned a lot of these
associations from all the raw data and
so that's the base right you've got this
base of all this raw data and then
you've trained a task specific thing
like a question answering system but
even then what we find is that if we
train a question answering system on
basic facts it doesn't always work well
when you go to operation manuals or
other things so then we have to have it
adapt so but like I said that base is
very helpful because it's already
learned a lot of characteristics of
language just by observing massive
amounts of text
[Music]
I'd like you to predict the future no
pressure
what's on the horizon for machine
reading comprehension research one of
the big challenges that lie ahead and
we've sort of laid the land out on what
we're doing now what next
yeah well certainly more complex
questions what we've been talking about
so far is still fairly simple in this
sense that you have a question and we
try to find passages of text that answer
that question but sometimes a question
actually requires that you get multiple
pieces of evidence from multiple places
and you somehow synthesize them together
so a simple example we called the multi
hop example if I ask a question like you
know where was Barack Obama's wife born
I have to figure out first who is Barack
Obama's wife and then I have to figure
out where she was born and those pieces
of information might be in two different
places so that's what we call a multi
hop question and then sometimes we have
to do some operation on the data so you
could say you know like what players you
know from one Super Bowl team also
played on another Super Bowl team well
there what you have to do is you have to
get a list of all the players from both
teams then you have to do an
intersection between them to figure out
which ones are the same on both so
that's an operation on the data and you
can imagine that there's lots of
questions like that where the
information is there but it's not enough
to just show the person where the
information is you also would like to go
a step further and actually do the
computation for that that's a step that
we haven't done like how do you actually
go from mapping text to text and saying
these two things are associated to
mapping text to some sequence of
operations that will actually give you
an exact answer and you know it can be
quite difficult I can give you a very
simple example like just answering a
question yes or no out of text is not a
solved problem let's say I have a
question where someone says I'm gonna
fly to London next week am I allowed to
fly business class according to my
policies for my company right we can
have a system that be really good at
finding the section of the policy that
says you know if you are a VP level or
higher and you're flying overseas you
can fly business class otherwise no
okay but you know if we actually want
the system to answer yes or no we have
to actually figure out all the details
like okay who's asking the question are
they a VP where are they located
oh they're New York what is flying
overseas mean their layers right yes so
that type of comprehension you know
we're not quite there yet for all types
of questions usually these things have
to be crafted by hand for specific
domains so all of these things about how
can you answer complex questions and
even simple things like common sense
like things that we all know and so my
manager Andrew McNamara he was supposed
to be here with us one of his favorite
examples is this concept of coffee being
black but if you spill coffee on your
shirt do you have a black stain on your
shirt no you've got a brown stain on
your shirt and that's just common
knowledge that is a you know a common
sense thing that computers may not
understand you're working on research
and ultimately products or product
features that make people think they can
talk to their machines and that their
machines can understand and talk back to
them so is there anything you find
disturbing about this anything that
keeps you up at night and if so how are
you dealing with it well I'm certainly
not worried about the fact that people
can ask questions of the computer and
and the computer can give them answers
what I'm trying to get at is something
that's helpful and can help me solve
tasks in terms of the work that we do
yeah there are actually issues that
concern me so one of the big ones is
even if a computer can say oh I found a
good answer for you here's the answer it
doesn't know anything about whether that
answer is true if you go and ask your
computer was the whole cost real and it
finds an article on the web that says no
the whole cost was a hoax do I want my
computer to show that answer no I don't
but or the moon-landing if all you're
doing is teaching the computer about
word associations it might think that's
a perfectly reasonable answer without
actually knowing that this is a horrible
answer to be showing so yeah the
moon-landing vaccinations the easy way
that people can defame people on the
Internet
you know even if you ask a question
that might seem like a fact-based
question you can get vast differences of
opinion on this and you can get
extremely biased and untrue answers and
how does the computer actually
understand that some of these things are
not things that we should represent as
truth right especially if your goal is
to find a truthful answer to a question
all right so then what do we do about
that and by we I mean you
well I have been working on this problem
a little bit with the Bing team and one
of the things that we discovered is that
if you can determine that a question is
phrased in a derogatory way that usually
means the search results that you're
going to get back are probably going to
be phrased in interrogatory way so even
if we don't understand the answer we can
just be very careful about what types of
questions we actually want to answer
well what does the world look like if
you're wildly successful
I want the systems that we build just
make life easier for people if you have
an information task the world is
successful if you get that piece of
information and you don't have to work
too hard to get it and we call task
completion if you have to struggle to
find an answer then we're not successful
but if you can ask a question and we can
get you the answer and you go yeah
that's the answer that's success to me
and will be wildly successful if the
types of things where that happens
become more more complex you know where
if someone could start asking questions
where you're synthesizing data and
computing answers from multiple pieces
of information for me that's the wildly
successful part and we're not there yet
with what we're going to deliver into
product but it's on the research horizon
it will be incremental it's not going to
happen all at once but I can see it
coming and hopefully by the time I
retire I can see significant progress in
that direction
I've script a little well I be talking
to my computer my phone hololens who am
i asking where am i asking what device
is that so out there as well yeah I
don't know how to think about where
devices are going you know when I was a
kid I watched the original Star Trek you
know and everything on there it seemed
like a wildly futuristic thing you know
and then 15 20 years later everybody's
got their own little come
you Nicator oh my and so you know the
fact that we're now beyond where Star
Trek predicted we would be you know that
itself is impressive to me so I don't
want to speculate where the devices are
going but I do think that this ability
to answer questions it's going to get
better and better we're gonna be more
interconnected we're gonna have more
access to data the range of things that
computers will be able to answer is
going to continue to expand and I'm not
quite sure exactly what it looks like in
the future to be honest but you know I
know it's going to get better and easier
to get information I'm a little less
worried about you know what the form
factor is going to be I'm more worried
about how I'm gonna actually answer
questions reliably well it's story time
tell us a little bit about yourself your
life your path to MSR how did you get
interested in computer science research
and how did you land where you are now
working from Microsoft Research in New
England for Montreal right well I've
never been once a long-term plan for
things I've always gone from what I find
interesting to the next thing I find
industry I never had a really serious
long-term goal I didn't wake up some
morning when I was seven and say oh I
want to be a principal research manager
at Microsoft in my future I didn't even
know what Microsoft was when I was seven
I went to college and I just knew I
wanted to study computers I didn't know
really what that meant at the time just
seemed really cool yeah I had a Apple
too when I was a kid and I learned how
to do some basic programming and then I
you know what's going through my
coursework
I was in my junior year I was taking a
course on audio signal processing and in
the course of that class we got into a
discussion about speech recognition
which to me was again it was Star Trek
it was something I saw on TV of course
now it was the next generation right but
you know you watch the next generation
of Star Trek and they're talking to the
computer and the computers giving them
answers and here somebody's telling me
you know there's this guy over in the
lab for computer science victor zue and
he's building systems that recognized
speech and give answers to questions and
to me that was science fiction so I went
over and
ask the guy you know I heard you
building the system and can I do my
bachelor's thesis on this and he gave me
a demo of this system it was called
Voyager and he asked a question I don't
remember the exact question is it was
probably something like show me a map of
Harvard Square and the system starts
chugging along and it's showing results
on the screen as it's going and it
literally took about two minutes for it
to process the whole thing it was long
enough that he actually explained to me
how the entire system worked while it
was processing but then it came back and
it popped up a map of Harvard Square on
the screen and I was like oh my gosh
this is so cool I have to do this so I
did my bachelor's thesis with him and
then I stayed on for graduate school and
by seven years later we had a system
that was running in real time we had a
publicly available system in 1997 that
you could call up on a toll-free number
and you could ask for weather reports
and weather information for anywhere in
the United States
Wow and so the idea that it went from
something that was Star Trek just
something that I could pick up my phone
call a number and you know show my
parents this is what I'm working on it
was astonishing how fast that developed
I stayed on in that field with that
research group I was at MIT for another
15 years after I graduated at some point
a lot of the things that we were doing
they moved from the research lab to
actually being real so like 20 years
after I went and asked to do my
bachelor's thesis Siri comes out okay
and so that was our gold like 20 years
ago we should be able to have a device
where you could talk to and it gives you
answers and 20 years later there it was
so that for me that was a cue that maybe
it's time to go where the action is
which was in companies that were
building these things once you have a
large company like Microsoft or Google
throwing their resources behind these
hard problems then you can't compete
when you're in academia for that space
you know you have to move on to
something harder and more far out but I
still really enjoyed it so I joined
Microsoft to work on Cortana when we
were building the first version of
Cortana and I spent a few years working
on that I've worked on some Bing
products I then spent some time and as
you're trying to transfer these things
so that companies that had the similar
types of problems could solve their
problems on Azure with our technology
and then we come full circle yeah you
know once I realized that some of the
stuff that customers were asking for
wasn't quite ready yet I said let me go
back to research and see if I can
improve that it's fantastic to see
something through all the way to product
but once you were successful and you
have something in a product it's nice to
then say okay what's the next hard
problem and then start over and work on
the next start problem before we wrap up
tell us one interesting thing about
yourself maybe it's a trait a
characteristic a life event a sidequest
whatever that people might not know or
be able to find on a basic web search
that's influenced your career as a
researcher okay you know when I was a
kid maybe about 11 years old the Rubik's
Cube came out and I got fascinated with
it and I wanted to learn how to solve it
and a kid down the street from my cousin
had taught it himself from a book how to
solve it and he taught me his name was
Jonathan Shire and he was actually in
the first national speed of solving
competition it was on this TV show
that's incredible I don't know if you
remember that TV show I do it turned out
what he did was he had learned what is
now known as the simple solution and I
learned it from him and I didn't realize
it till many years later but what I
learned was an algorithm I learned you
know a sequence of steps to solve a
problem and once I got into computer
science I discovered well hold that
problem-solving I was doing with the
Rubik's Cube and figuring out what are
the steps to solve a problem that's
essentially what things like machine
learning are doing what are the steps to
figure out what are the features of
something what are the steps I have to
do to solve a problem I didn't realize
that at the time but the idea of being
able to break down a hard problem
solving a Rubik's Cube and figuring out
what are the stages to get you there is
interesting now here's the interesting
fact so Jonathan Shire his older brother
is Adam Shire Adam Shire is one of the
cofounders of Siri oh my gosh are you
kidding me so I met the kid when I was
young and we didn't really stay in touch
I discovered you know many years later
that Adam Shire was actually the older
brother of this kid who taught me the
Rubik's Cube years and years earlier and
Jonathan ended up at Siri also so it's
an interesting coincidence
that we ended up working in the same
field after all those years from this
Rubik's Cube connection you see this is
my favorite question now because I'm
getting the broadest spectrum of little
things that influenced and triggered
something at the end of every podcast I
give my guests a chance for the
proverbial last word here's your chance
to say anything you want to would-be
researchers both applied and otherwise
who might be interested in working on
machine reading comprehension for
real-world applications well I could say
all the things that you would expect me
to say like you should learn about deep
learning algorithms and you should
possibly learn Python because that's
what everybody is using these days but I
think the single most important thing
that I can tell anybody wants to get
into a field like this is that you need
to explore it and you need to figure out
how it works and do something in depth
don't just get some instruction set or
some high level overview on the internet
run it on your computer and then say oh
I think I understand this like get into
the nitty-gritty of it become an expert
and the other thing I could say is of
all the people I've met who are
extremely successful the thing that sets
them apart isn't so much you know what
they learn it's the initiative that they
took so if you see a problem try to fix
it
if you see a problem try to find a
solution for it and I say this to people
who work for me if you really want to
have an impact don't just do what I tell
you to do but explore think outside the
box
try different things okay I'm not gonna
have the answer to everything so
therefore if I don't have the answer to
everything
then if you're only doing what I'm
telling you to do then we both together
aren't gonna have the answer but if you
explore things on your own and take the
initiative and try to figure out
something that's the best way to really
be successful
TJ Hazen thanks for coming in today all
the way from the East Coast to talk to
us it's been delightful thank you it's
been a pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. TJ Hazen and how
researchers and engineers are teaching
machines to answer complicated questions
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]